ومع استقبالك يا دفعه القنابل العنقوديه
قال قائد القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
فاليري زالوجني لي واشنطن بوست ان طريقه
قتال العدو من مسؤوليه الاوكرانيين وانه
اذا كان الشركاء يخشون استخدام اسلحتهم
فان الجيش الاوكراني سيستخدم اسلحته لكن
فقط بقدر ما يلزم قائد القوات الاوكرانيه
اضاف انه لا يحتاج الى ان يطلب الاذن بشان
ما يفعله على ارض العدو لانقاذ شعبه حسب
تعبيره واوضح ان شنه هجوم مضاد لاستعاده
الاراضي المحتله والحاق الهزيمه بروسيا
وتقليل خسائر اوكرانيا يتطلب موارد لا
تزال تفتقر اليها بلاده واشار الى انه في
الوقت الذي يمتلك فيه الاوكرانيون الوسائل
فلن يستطيع احد ايقافهم عن استعاده شبه
جزيره القرم
هذا واقرت رئاسه الاوكرانيه بان الهجوم
المضاده الذي تشنه القوات الاوكرانيه لا
يحرز تقدما سريعا واضافت ان الحلفاء
الغربيين لا يمارسون ضغطا على كياف هذا
الصدد مشيرا الى ان اوكرانيا ترفض اجراء
اي مفاوضات مع روسيا قبل سحب قوتها